[Musique]
bienvenue dans des bases sur France 24
consacrés aux élections mi-mandat aux
États-Unis les Américains élisent les
députés de la Chambre des Représentants
un tiers des sénateurs mais aussi les
gouverneurs de 36 états c'est un scrutin
crucial bien sûr pour Joe Biden car les
démocrates risquent de perdre la chambre
mais aussi le Sénat tout dépendra bien
sûr du taux de participation la campagne
très polarisée a vu s'affronter Joe
Biden et Donald Trump venu soutenir
leurs candidat alors ces élections
sont-elles un test pour la démocratie
américaine quel est le rapport de force
entre démocrate et républicain quel
impact sur la politique de Joe Biden en
cas de victoire des républicains Donald
Trump va-t-il prendre sa revanche on va
poser ses questions à nos invités j'ai
le plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés et me
porter bonsoir bienvenue à vous
porte-parole du Parti démocrate en
France en face de vous Vanessa
biarchefort bonsoir vous êtes
vice-présidente des républicaines
overses en France également bienvenue à
dans le débat Julia soulier avec nous
bonsoir spécialiste des États-Unis à
l'Université d'Artois et puis nous avons
en direct de New York John Rick McArthur
directeur du mensuel harpes magazine
bonjour à vous John Rick et bienvenue
merci nous allons nous allons faire
intervenir d'ailleurs nos envoyer
spéciaux en Géorgie mais aussi en
Arizona pendant cette émission mais tout
d'abord justement on va faire un petit
point sur ce que sont ces meeterm les
Américains je vous le disais vote pour
ces élections mi-mandat 43 millions
d'entre eux ont d'ailleurs déjà voté par
anticipation le scrutin concerne donc la
Chambre des Représentants un tiers des
sénateurs mais aussi un certain nombre
d'élections locales ont fait le point
avec Nadia Makhloufi
c'est une épreuve pour chaque président
des États-Unis une élection pile à la
moitié de son monde du résultat de ce
scrutin dépend sa marche de manœuvre à
la Chambre des Représentants d'abord où
l'ensemble des 435 sièges et mis en jeu
cette Chambre basse du Congrès est
actuellement contrôlée par les
démocrates avec 221 fauteuils contre 211
pour les républicains le Sénat autre
échelon du pouvoir sans sénateur et
siège et un tiers de cette renouveler
tous les deux ans soit 35 fauteuils en
jeu pour cette élection l'influence des
démocraties particulièrement fragile
grâce au soutien de deux sénateurs
indépendants le camp présidentiel
totalisent 56 siège c'est une égalité
parfaite c'est donc la voix décisive de
la vice-présidente kamalaris qui fait la
différence sur la trentaine de sièges en
jeu le scrutin s'annonce très serré dans
au moins quatre états la Géorgie le
viscontine le Nevada et la Pennsylvanie
à l'échelle plus locale les Américains
sont également appelés à désigner les
gouverneurs dans 36 états considéré
comme un référendum sur l'action du
président s'est mites termes sont très
souvent synonymes de défaites à de rares
exceptions le parti au pouvoir perd
systématiquement des sièges au Congrès
et à quelques jours du vote la cote de
popularité de Joe Biden et plombé 39%
selon le dernier sondage Ret
si les républicains parviennent à
s'imposer au Congrès il bloqueront
l'action de l'exécutif il pourrait même
empêcher le président de nommer les
magistrats de son choix à la Cour
suprême
on va tout de suite en Géorgie retrouver
Julie dungelhoff notre envoyé spécial
vous êtes devant un bureau de vote Julie
dans un quartier afro-américain
d'Atlanta un quartier on vote plutôt
démocrate
oui tout à fait en 2020 pour vous donner
un élément de comparaison 88% de la
population afro-américaine de Géorgie
avait voté pour Joe Biden et vous dire
et bien que ici dans ce quartier on voit
principalement des panneaux en faveur
des démocrates des différents candidats
que ça soit pour le poste de gouverneur
ou encore le poste de sénateur alors
comme vous pouvez sans doute le voir il
n'y a pas beaucoup de monde pour
l'instant ici mais cela ne veut pas dire
que la mobilisation n'est pas importante
la directrice du bureau de vote nous
disait tout à l'heure que dès 6h30 ce
matin alors que les bureaux de vote
ouvraient à 7h et bien il y avait une
longue file d'attente devant pour votre
vote pour que les gens aillent voter que
probablement entre un peu plus tard dans
la journée il y aurait à nouveau une
influence et ce qu'elle me disait aussi
c'est que cela ne voulait pas dire que
la mobilisation n'était pas importante
pour ce vote puisque il y a eu un record
de vote anticipée de millions 500 000
personnes ont choisi de voter soit
physiquement dans un bureau de vote de
manière anticipée soit par voie postale
c'est un bureau de vote ici en tout cas
dans ce comté qui s'appelle le comté de
Fulton qui est particulièrement
surveillé parce qu'il y avait eu des
particularité en 2020 et donc on a pu
rentrer dans ce bureau de vote on a vu
en effet qu'il y avait eu quelques
observateurs ce que nous disent les gens
après avoir voté donc des électeurs
principalement démocrates c'est que il
vote parce que c'est leur seul manière
de faire entendre leur voix qui sont
très inquiets pour la démocratie
notamment au vu des candidats qui se
présentent du côté républicain et toutes
les femmes avec lesquelles nous avons pu
parler nous ont parlé et bien de leur
crainte que le droit à l'avortement soit
remise en cause ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose qu'on a pu entendre ces
derniers jours de la part de nombreuses
femmes donc électricité démocrate merci
beaucoup Julie Julie zingoloff donc en
Géorgie dans la banlieue d'Atlanta
hémiporteur on voit bien donc ce qui est
en jeu dans ce scrutin mais on parle
d'une vague rouge en tout cas les
républicains le disent est-ce que les
démocrates peuvent encore limiter la
casse
je ne crois pas du tout à la vague rouge
non
je sais mais le problème des sondages
c'est qu'ils se sont trompés en 2016 ils
se sont trompés en 2018 quand ils ont
massivement sous-estimé la vague bleue
effectivement qu'on avait eu à cette
époque là
d'autant plus que ces dernières semaines
on a vu arriver un
inondé le marché des sondages que je ne
peux appeler autre que sondage poubelle
financé par les républicains qui donnent
comme par hasard toujours les
républicains gagnants donc tout est
possible tout est possible surtout que
les femmes comme on vient de voir dans
le reportage sont vraiment très très
mobilisés cette idée et les femmes
votent plutôt démocrates parce qu'elles
ne votent pas toutes mais déjà les
femmes voient plus que les hommes aux
États-Unis et c'est vrai que toutes les
femmes de votre part démocrate mais une
grande partie des femmes vote démocrate
bien sûr donc ça va dépendre du taux de
participation vous êtes d'accord Vanessa
bière Schaeffer c'est vrai qu'on parle
d'une vague rouge un côté républicain
Trump a été beaucoup utilisé d'ailleurs
un certain nombre d'élus enfin en tout
cas ou de futurs élus est-ce que c'est
le cas ça va être une rose il y a
plusieurs questions une on va on va
reprendre les sondages ce que disent les
républicains nous républicains
réussissent France on est très on est
très précautionneux on n'a pas encore
les résultats il est frais que c'est
quand même fréquent qu'il y a une
changement de majorité quand un
président d'une couleur le Congrès passe
d'une autre couleur c'est classique il
est vrai que les femmes votent beaucoup
mais il est vrai aussi quand nous avons
des problèmes économiques une inflation
galopante des problèmes économiques liés
quand même un des la situation du covid
qui a fermé de nombreux petits business
et de petites activités qui font vivre
la majorité des gens et une mère qui ne
peut pas nourrir ses enfants
va effectivement aller voter donc vous
dites finalement ce scrutin il se fait
sur le bilan économique oui
principalement
Julie assoulis c'est vrai qu'il y a
plusieurs thèmes qu'on a vu pendant
cette campagne en particulier
l'inflation donc la hausse des prix
que vous venez de parler elle a pris
vraiment on peut dire elle est vraiment
au centre de cette campagne plus que les
autres thèmes où il y a celui de la
sécurité aussi immigration et puis
l'avortement pour les pour les
démocrates mais est-ce que finalement la
hausse du prix de l'essence est devenu
je dirais le sujet de la bataille
électorale oui le problème c'est que
quand jobidan a été élu l'inflation
était de 2% et aujourd'hui elle a
atteint presse que 8% 8%. donc il y a
une hausse de l'inflation assez
vertigineuse qui est inhabituelle aux
États-Unis le problème aussi c'est que
les républicains ont tendance à ne pas
regarder la conjoncture
globale et donc ne pas prendre en compte
la guerre en Ukraine ne pas prendre en
compte le fait que cette tendance à
l'inflation galopante elle est partout
en fait dans le monde et pas uniquement
aux États-Unis mais évidemment c'est
c'est un argument politique de campagne
et ça Persique pendant la campagne on va
écouter Joe Biden
aujourd'hui nous sommes à un moment
charnière l'un de ces moments qui se
présente toutes les trois ou quatre
générations nous savons viscéralement
que notre démocratie est en danger le
moment est venu pour vous de la défendre
de la préserver de la protéger et je
veux que vous sachiez que nous serons au
rendez-vous
souvenez-vous-en le pouvoir en Amérique
est là où il a toujours été entre vos
mains les mains du peuple
dans ces élections est-ce que Joe Biden
a raison de dire que finalement c'est un
défi pour la démocratie américaine ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui
il faut préciser que les démocrates ne
cessent d'accuser les républicains et
surtout les partisans de Trump d'être
des fascistes carrément des fascistes et
qu'on est menacé par un une montée une
vague de fascisme qui va qui va détruire
la démocratie alors moi je trouve ça
exagéré bien sûr je suis pas du tout
d'accord avec l'idée de trempe comme
fasciste ou de rangeons dans l'état de
whiska c'est d'être un fasciste mais ce
que ça démontre c'est que les démocrates
sont désespérées ils n'ont pas un
programme vraiment qu'on peut qu'on
puisse présenter au peuple américain en
leur disant nous avons réussi à vous
aider vous les pauvres vous les moyens
vous les gens qui qui ont votent par
frustration
en 2016 donc il y a aussi une grande
partie du Parti démocrate qui est déçu
par le manque réforme et je parle
notamment du birbagber et je peux
discuter avec mon collègue démocrate là
mais c'était un échec
on blâme deux sénateurs joomen et
Christine cinéma mais moi je suis pas
tout à fait d'accord je vois dans tout
cela un manque de foi
de la part de bail qui a permis au
programme de burnison d'échouer
finalement il ne va pas il n'a pas
défendu parce que finalement c'était le
programme de burnisanders grande dépense
sur les pauvres
impôts crédit pour des enfants
hausse de salaire minimum tout ce qui
est démocratie sociale a été retiré de
de du projet loi
c'est pas simplement la rancune des
républicains ou la la peur la peur de
l'inflation l'immigration illégale etc
c'est aussi c'est une déception de la
part d'une grande minorité disons de
l'électeur a qui a voté pour être contre
Trump où ils sont simplement votés
contre Trump parce qu'ils avaient peur
de trempe Amy porter vous peut-être
réagir à ce que vient de dire Jonak
McArthur
je dirais que il faut regarder le bilan
quand même depuis deux ans
l'administration bydenas a fait passer
une quantité innombrable de loi ça a été
des deux ans les plus efficaces qu'on
ait vu depuis des années alors je les
cite l'inscription du droit à l'avoir
faim volonté d'inscrire le droit
avortement la Constitution annulation
partielle de la dette étudiante qui
concerne 43 millions de personnes
effacement des condamnations pour
possession de consommation de loi sur
les infrastructures 1200 milliards ça
c'était transpartisan loi sur les
semi-conducteurs 200 milliards sur 50
une inflation à 8,5% mais c'est
intéressant parce que ce que vous dites
il a quand même fait des choses mais on
a l'impression que la perception des
Américains n'est pas celle-là
c'est-à-dire que à la gauche en tout cas
ils n'ont pas l'impression que il est
vraiment il est peut-être pas aller
assez loin les 35 % de l'électorat qui
votent Trump votre ampotrope peu importe
ce que fait Trump parce que dit Trump
hier Trump a dit qu'il fallait mettre
tous les journalistes en prison vous
serez heureux de le savoir il a dit
qu'il fallait abattre les dealers de
drogue et envoyer la balle à leur
famille l'économie ne s'est jamais porté
aussi bien or l'inflation que Joe Biden
ne peut pas contrôler il est pas le
président ne peut pas influer sur sur
l'inflation nous savons tous ici en
France on a le même problème ce qu'ils
ont pu faire donc c'était de passer des
lois qui réduisent les coûts de
l'énergie qui réduisent les coûts des
médicaments pour aider justement les
gens à c'est pas un problème de
pédagogie côté démocrate émis porteur de
pédagogie entre la perception justement
des Américains est-ce qu'il a pu faire
déjà il y a et puis bon j'imagine que
vous avez aussi un commentaire à faire
Vanessa Garcia il faut quand même parler
de ce qui s'est passé lors du covid
toutes les petites entreprises
je peux je peux terminer
plein de petites entreprises de petits
artisans de gens de commerçants ont été
complètement éliminés la communauté les
communautés noires ont été les premières
touchées c'est un massacre on nous parle
de milliards on voit alors je veux dire
la différence entre la carte et le
territoire la carte c'est oui on
investit on fait ceci mais concrètement
dans la vie quotidienne des gens et des
américains ils n'envoient pas les effets
et ils sont fatigués et effectivement
s'il y a un double effet à mon avis au
niveau électoral des républicains qui
vont continuer à voter républicains et
le centre gauche qui était démocrate qui
ne votent plus démocrate parce qu'entre
ce que entre les discours la réalité
quotidienne Trump ou sans Trump je veux
dire personnellement je les démocrates
ramène toujours le sujet sur Trump parce
que justement ils ne veulent pas
débattre des vrais sujets et des vrais
problèmes des Américains on a
l'impression que les républicains
avaient besoin de Trump pendant cette
campagne
de Santis en Floride personnellement
c'est la génération excusez-moi pour
ceux qui ont un certain âge plus âgés ou
baby qui sont les baby boomers ils n'ont
pas laissé les générations suivantes le
leadership se renouvelait dans leur
partie et démocrates en particulier
républicains aussi et là il va falloir
qu’émerge des nouveaux leaders si on
veut que les démocrates et les
républicains parce que un système de
partie unique personne n'en veut ni
républicain ni démocrate ils vont
toujours une opposition pour qu'un
système démocrate fonctionne de manière
équilibrée mais il va falloir
excusez-moi un Biden c'est un
quelquefois c'est c'est on voit bien que
c'est un système qui est arrivé en bout
de temps il a un problème d'image
celui-là jamais il n'imprime pas
choisie
après pardon et là il a pas été choisi
parce que il avait un fort soutien du
côté démocrates il a été choisi pour
contrer Donald Trump donc partant de là
sa popularité même quand il a commencé à
être enfin sa présidence n'était pas
très haute il est il est très vite tombé
en fait son taux de popularité au bout
d'un an à fortement baissé mais je pense
pas que ce soit le problème fondamental
en fait le problème le problème
fondamental c'est que
la polarisation qui à court aux
États-Unis depuis maintenant un certain
temps et qui s'est intensifié sous l'air
Trump n'a jamais cessé Donald Trump
quand il a été déclaré perdant n'a
jamais concédé et le fait de ne pas
concéder à continuer à attiser beaucoup
de beaucoup de violence au cœur du pays
et je pense que Biden n'a pas pu
réellement développer
mon programme d'unités à cause de
justement cette ces gens qui ont nié les
résultats d'élection et quand il dit
qu'il y a un problème démocratique je
pense que c'est lié en fait assez
personne qui nie les résultats de
l'élection et la plupart 60% des
républicains qui sont candidats ni les
résultats des élections ce qui est ce
qui est quand même problématique John
vous êtes d'accord alors c'est vrai que
les sondages le montrent que les
républicains pensent toujours que une
partie des républicains pense toujours
que l'élection a été volée
il y a toujours des fous furieux un peu
partout j'en ai vu hier j'étais sur le
terrain et il y a le républicain Lizard
candidat pour être gouverneur de l'été à
New York c'est un fou il dit des choses
incroyablement stupides et il est sur le
point de gagner contre la la gouverneur
sortante mais pour revenir sur bail
c'est pas une question d'image c'est une
question de fait il a été choisi
excusez-moi mon collègue démocrate
il a été choisi pour contrer il a été il
a émis porteur il a été choisi pour
contrer et détruire la candidature de
Bernie senders d'abord et avant tout
après il est devenu le candidat en titre
c'est vrai
son programme c'était un programme de
maintenir l'équilibre dans son parti
et enfin quand il a accédé au au
revendications d'un certain job and Chun
et pas ce sel de
maintien au téléspectateurs
du Parti démocrate et qui s'est opposé à
un certain nombre de réformes je note
juste en passant que baiden a quand même
gagné donc
excusez-moi excusez-moi et encore une
petite précision un clientélisme qui a
été récompensé lui et sa femme par bye
directement directement
elle a été nommée à la tête d'une grande
commission de je ne sais pas régional
dans Virginie
occidentale ou elle aura le droit de
dépenser des milliards des milliards de
dollars voilà John Drake
juste trois quarts des Américains
d'après ce que j'ai lu pense que là
démocratie est menacée donc républicain
et démocrate on Arizona c'est en tout
cas l'un des états clés de ces élections
il y a eu des tensions auprès des
bureaux de vote vous allez risque
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux loïdes
Kiala à tout seul justement en Arizona
et on le retrouve ensuite
une émission très marquée à droite au
programme ce jour-là de nouveau doute
sur les élections de 2020
ceux qui contestent le résultat du
scrutin yes oui je crois que la fraude a
été généralement les officiels
démocrates ont changé la façon de
compter
si vous envoyez votre bulletin par la
poste 12 paires de mains le manipule qui
sait ce qui peut arriver
alors Garette Lewis et d'autres
demandent la fin du vote par
correspondance le risque de fraude est
trop grand selon eux même si aucune
étude ne le confirme ils ne veulent pas
non plus du vote anticipé en Arizona
comme dans ce bureau on peut déposer son
bulletin en personne depuis près d'un
mois et Mark Fincher est à leur écoute
cet ancien policier Brig le poste de
secrétaire d'État en Arizona autrement
dit l'homme qui supervise les production
dans l'état il assure qu'en 2020 il
n'aurait pas certifié le résultat de la
présidentielle
on s'interroge juste sur le résultat
prendra un mois
d'élection je réponds que la France
compte 64 millions de bulletins de vote
il me semble que c'est ombre là en une
seule journée
mais la vraie star c'est Kerry Lake une
journaliste de télévision devenue
candidate au poste de gouverneur elle ne
croit pas non plus aux résultats de 2020
le New York Times la décrit comme une
Donald Trump avec du rouge à lèvres
j'aime bien demander ça en présence des
fake news combien d'entre vous ne
regardent plus les fake news la
frontière pose problème depuis des
années les politiciens promettent de
changer les choses depuis des années
mais personne n'a jamais rien fait
jusqu'à l'arrivée du président Trump
chez ses sympathisant on rejette
l'appellation d'élections d'inailleurs
nous avons beaucoup de questions
toujours sans réponse répondez-nous
l'Arizona aura donc les yeux rivés sur
les centres de dépouillement cette nuit
les résultats s'annoncent très serrés
pas de quoi apaiser les doutes d'une
partie des votants
direction tout de suite tout seul en
Arizona on retrouve justement Loïc piala
notre envoyé spécial Loïc vous avez donc
fait ce reportage alors vous êtes devant
un bureau de vote là à tout sonne est-ce
que les choses sont un peu plus apaisés
quel est l'ambiance on a vu que tout de
même eu des tensions auprès près des
bureaux de vote pendant ces dernières
semaines on Arizona
alors dans ce bureau de vote ici à tout
seul tout se passe bien les membres de
l'organisation élections protection nous
l'ont confirmé le bureau de vote est
ouvert depuis 6h du matin les membres
d'élection de l'élection ce sont ces
femmes de que vous voyez derrière moi
avec un t-shirt violet une organisation
apolitique qui assiste les électeurs
mais plus au nord dans le comté de Mary
coppa autour de Phoenix là où vote deux
tiers des arizoniens un bureau sur 5
aurait rencontré des problèmes
techniques avec cette machine qui permet
d'enregistrer les votes alors c'est un
bug mineur les votes seront
comptabilisés un peu plus tard mais dans
le climat défiance dont on vient de
parler dans le sujet précédent
évidemment que ça ne va pas rassurer ces
milliers d'arizoniens qui doutent du
résultat des élections de 2020 qui
s'interrogent sur les résultats à venir
aujourd'hui on peut voter ici depuis le
12 octobre en vote anticiper et
notamment via des Dropbox sort de boîte
à lettres dans lequel on peut déposer
son bulletin et des citoyens inquiets se
sont à positionner à proximité de ces
boîtes à lettres pour filmer pour
prendre en photo des plaques
d'immatriculation pour s'assurer que et
bien on ne bourrait pas les urnes
sachant qu'on peut tout à fait déposer
plusieurs bulletins les membres se des
membres de sa famille par exemple un
juge a estimé qu'il s'agissait là d'une
intimidation des électeurs il leur a
demandé de se tenir à 25 mètres au moins
de ces boîtes à lettres et même à 60
mètres pour les observateurs armés nous
sommes en Arizona on a le droit de
porter une arme en public ici merci Loïc
Loïc piala donc en direct de tout ça une
Vanessa biarchefergement vous faire
réagir tout de même sur ce comportement
le fait qu'effectivement une grande
partie de la République pense encore que
l'élection de Biden a été volée on a vu
ces dinars donc ces personnes qui doute
celle de Trump pardon a été volé les
dinayeuls qui doutent donc du des
résultats du scrutin est-ce que ça n'est
pas là une vraie menace pour la
démocratie américaine alors ça c'est la
propagande actuelle c'est la propagande
vous dites et c'est moi terminé je suis
d'accord avec votre invité de rappeur je
pense que il y a toujours dans certains
camps et que vous preniez républicains
ou démocrates et jusque boutiste des
gens qui sont excité qui sont aussi
énervés si vous avez jamais organisé un
scrutin vous savez qu'il faut un certain
protocole pour justement calmer les
esprits pas forcément de gens qui ont
l'air a priori dangereux je pense que
c'est une propagande qui vise à
discréditer si vous voulez le clan
républicain alors que par exemple
de qui vous prenez des exemples extrêmes
et vous en faites une généralité je veux
dire c'est de bonne guerre ça fait
partie des techniques de campagne
politique donc pour vous il n'y a pas de
problème démocratique aux États-Unis le
problème alors s'il y a si on est en est
arrivé là c'est que techniquement il y a
des questions qui se posent sur
l'organisation des élections donc à ce
moment là il faut que les deux camps les
deux parties se réunissent et trouvent
des solutions concrètes c'est pas la
peine de projeter l'eau propre sur des
gens qui sont convaincus qu'il y a des
des abus ce qu'il faut c'est donner des
réponses techniques juridiques et
organisées regardez le système électoral
en France
je crois qu'il se passe généralement
très bien donc ça peut c'est possible de
comparer mais le fait que Donald Trump
était toujours pas reconnu par exemple
le fait que Donald Trump
est toujours sur Trump c'est on revient
toujours sur Trump et actuellement c'est
parti j'ai mal je peux terminer
vous revenez toujours sur Trump il n'est
pas président aujourd'hui c'est Biden
ils ont les démocrates ont la majorité
nous sommes dans les meetum donc parlons
du bilan des démocrates si on revient
peut-être que dans 10 ans mais peut-être
que dans 10 ans encore on parlera de
Trump moi je veux bien mais on parlera
aussi encore de Kennedy dans 20 ans
peut-être mais effectivement les
Américains pensent quand même ils sont
trois quarts à penser qu'il y a des
problèmes de démocratie dans ce pays
donc vous pouvez répondre peut-être à ce
que vient de dire est-ce qu'on est dans
de la propagande est-ce que c'est
effectivement une toute petite minorité
des républicains qui pensent que
l'élection a été volée ou est-ce qu'au
contraire le parti il y a une grande
partie de ce parti qui pense toujours
cela donc une vraie défiance à l'égard
des institutions d'aujourd'hui vous avez
300 candidats qui nient les résultats de
l'élection de 2020 pour des chansons
clés comme secrétaire d'État et
procure générale de chaque État ce sont
les gens qui régissent les élections
donc si nous lisons là maintenant des
gens qui ont déjà dit comme Kary light
que venait de montrer en Arizona qui ont
déjà dit qu'ils ne vont pas certifier
les résultats de l'élection tout ça
c'est pour préparer 2024 quand Donald
Trump va se représenter d'ailleurs il va
annoncer le 15 novembre c'est peut-être
un scoop mais c'est vrai et en 2024 ils
vont dire ah non on n'arrive pas à
compter l'élection n'a pas été légitime
et donc Trump devient dictateur à vie
donc c'est l'imaginer vous êtes en train
de dire merci d'avoir 300 candidats
aujourd'hui qui ont déjà annoncé la
couleur qui vont pas certifier les
élections je voudrais quand même revenir
rapidement sur la mauvaise foi de venir
ça de tout à l'heure parce qu'on est
habitué à la mauvaise foi des
républicains mais là c'est olympique de
se dire que le covid c'était la faute de
Biden mes souvenirs sans bande janvier
2020 en janvier 2021 c'est Donald Trump
qui était Président et on a eu un
million de morts de covid grâce à son
ingérence dans dans cette pandémie donc
c'est la faute de Bailleul je pense les
répercussions sur l'économie j'ai les
chiffres on a 10 millions de postes
créés en deux ans le chômage n'a jamais
été aussi bas il y a deux postes pour
chaque chômeur aujourd'hui arrêtons avec
les républicains sont meilleurs pour
l'économie c'est démontrablement faux
Julia solit toujours pour revenir sur
cette menace de la démocratie américaine
je lisais donc un papier de degrés
Kennedy un écrivain américain évidemment
démocrate il faut le dire mais lui pense
que on va que finalement si les
républicains sont victorieux l'Amérique
deviendra je le cite à une théocratie
ultralibérale qui pourra déboucher sur
une guerre de Sécession il dit les côtes
est et ouest formeront une nouvelle
république et c'est pas le seul
d'ailleurs à écrire ça on est un petit
peu enfin c'est ce qu'il dit un certain
nombre d'intellectuels le disent comme
avant la guerre de Sécession et on
pourrait se retrouver avec un pays
totalement divisé et effectivement une
nouvelle République entre les États
démocrates et puis de l'autre côté les
états républicains c'est un scénario
possible c'est un scénario catastrophe
faut quand même le rappeler mais il est
vrai que les blessures de la guerre de
Sécession n'ont jamais guéri preuve en
est le fait que ce qu'on appelle aux
États-Unis le voter surpression qui
consiste à retracer les districts par
exemple dans certains états ou pour
priver la communauté noire de ces voix a
toujours existé existe encore Donald
Trump aujourd'hui est sous le fait d'une
accusation d'avoir essayé de convaincre
le procureur la personne qui est en
charge de compter les votes en Géorgie
de arrêter de compter les votes en gros
et de lui donner le nombre de voix dont
il avait besoin pour remporter l'état
donc ça c'est une preuve oui que la que
la démocratie est en danger et je
comprends complètement ce que dit de
gloss Canada à ce sujet là parce que
effectivement les tensions sont-elles et
le déni de démocratie est-elle certains
états que ça devient très préoccupant
mais comparé avec la France n'est pas
chose possible puisque le système
électoral est différent dans chaque État
aux États-Unis alors qu'en France il est
unifié donc on ne peut pas du tout
comparer les deux systèmes John Rick
est-ce que le pays va imploser est-ce
qu'il peut imploser comme dit Douglas
Kennedy
je veux pas jouer le rôle de du docteur
panglos dans Candide mais il faut dire
que il y a le bon côté du trapisme il y
a très peu à louer là c'est le fait
qu'il a suscité une participation énorme
dans le scrutin de 2020 donc moi je vois
une un taux de participation dans la
démocratie américaine
plus élevé plus plus enthousiaste et
donc c'est pas tout à fait horrible que
Trump soit tellement horrible mais
d'autre part il faut dire que c'est pas
un manque tellement de de fois dans la
démocratie il y a un manque de
d'éducation chez les électeurs on a
complètement perdu notre pas
complètement nous avons perdu une grande
une grande partie de notre sentiment
notre esprit civique aux États-Unis
l'idée de la citoyenneté est en
disparition et c'est pas les démocrates
qui fait qui fait leur mieux vraiment de
leur renforcer malheureusement
les républicains les gens comme Lisa
Alden sont pires mais il y a pas une il
n'y a pas un consensus sur l'idée de la
démocratie l'idée d'un citoyenneté aux
États-Unis il y a plus il y a il y a des
sentiments de rancune de ressentiment
contre les élites et comme je dis
toujours ça remonte au traité aux
accords de libre-échange promulgués par
nous avons une classe ouvrière
complètement aliénée qui a été dépouillé
par les politiques la politique bi
partisan de Clinton et de bouche et il y
a tout tout notre emploi c'est un peu
gouvernement en France je le dis je le
répète les anciens communistes les
anciens communistes dans le Nord qui
votent Front national c'est pas
tellement différent chez nous les
anciens syndicalistes qui travaillaient
dans des usines d'automobile qui
aujourd'hui vote pour 30 pour votre pour
ce type jdence dans l'état de l'oral qui
est un faucheton on peut pas imaginer un
pire Fauchon mais maintenant il a
convaincu une bonne partie de la classe
ouvrière dans l'état de high c'est lui
qui est vraiment le champion de la de la
classe ouvrière ce qui est ridicule
c'est risible on va voir tout de même
l'impact Corée sur la politique de Joe
Biden une victoire des républicains
est-ce qu'effectivement l'invention Act
perdurerait le plan infrastructure et
puis surtout l'aide américaine à
l'Ukraine on sait que c'est l'un des
enjeux de cette élection il n'y a qu'à
écouter volody mirzelinski le qui sait
exprimer aujourd'hui à ce sujet
je vous demande de maintenir une unité
inébranlable comme c'est déjà le cas et
ce jusqu'au jour où nous entendrons tous
ces mots importants dont nous avons rêvé
jusqu'à ce que nous entendions que la
paix a finalement été rétabli
les démocraties ne doivent pas s'arrêter
en chemin vers la victoire
le résultat du scrutin est-ce que
effectivement cette aide américaine à
l'Ukraine peut changer si les
républicains l'emportent alors je ne
peux pas vous dire ce qui va se passer
je peux juste vous dire ce que les uns
et les autres ont dit donc du côté
démocrate on ne change pas de position
du côté républicain on voit là on va là
le il y a quand même une scission
aujourd'hui dans le parti républicain
vous avez le leader du Sénat qui a dit
l'Ukraine en les touchera pas et le
leader
futur peut-être leader de la chambre qui
dit ce n'est plus un chèque en blanc
mais si les républicains passent de
toute façon dans la chambre pendant deux
ans il y aura personne ne va gouverner
ils vont juste lancer des investigations
se venger contre les démocrates et ça
sera le chaos et la cohabitation dans la
pire des situations
il peut y avoir un basculement dans
l'aide attendez je vous ferai réagir
après je voudrais juste laisser Vanessa
Biard chauffeur justement sur cette aide
à l'Ukraine est-ce que parce qu'on a vu
effectivement que un certain nombre de
républicains commencent à être plus
frileux en tout cas leaders
effectivement la chambre McCarthy a bien
expliqué que si les républicains étaient
élus il n'y aurait pas de chèques en
blanc à l'Ukraine qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire c'est qu'ils veulent de la country
ils veulent savoir où va l'argent
comment ça se passe parce qu'il y a
quand même des questions qui se posent
sur comment l'argent est alloué à
l'Ukraine ou à d'autres à d'autres
événements internationaux
et quand vous avez une population
américaine donc 40% n'a plus d'économie
80% ne peut pas ou à des difficultés
même pour
subvenir à ses besoins une famille de
deux enfants c'est à peu près les
chiffres qu'on a et il est normal que
les électeurs se demandent ou passent
l'argent du budget fédéral donc ça veut
dire qui est en déficit donc ça veut
dire qu'il y a une grande chance que
effectivement c'était d'américaine soit
diminué si les républicains obtiennent
la majorité c'est que s'il y a une aide
et au ciné que ça soit pour l'Ukraine ou
pour autre chose il faut qu'il y ait une
transparence il suffit pas de dire
écoutez c'est quand même il y a quelque
chose d'un peu choquant de voir un
leader un représentant d'un pays
étranger demander aux États-Unis il me
faut tant il faut etc enfin il y a quand
même c'est irréel l'image est irréelle
donc on voit quand même votre
positionnement différent de celui de Joe
Biden Julia soulier non je pense pas que
ce soit si réel que ça puisque ça a déjà
eu cours par le passé les États-Unis ont
quand même une position sur géopolitique
très importante notamment une position
de défenseur de la démocratie en
l'occurrence et je pense que la position
de Joe Biden est justement axée sur
cette tradition de de défendre la
démocratie là où elle est en danger bon
effectivement c'est pas une mesure qui
est très populaire chez les partisans
républicains pour les raisons que vous
donniez à l'instant et bon c'est pas du
tout surprenant effectivement à chaque
fois qu'il y a eu des crises économiques
ou l'inflation était élevée les
Américains ont eu tendance par le vote à
se retrancher sur les problèmes
américains et a plutôt se concentrer sur
sur ces problèmes là donc de façon non
surprenante si les républicains
l'emportent il y a de fortes chances oui
pour que pour que le budget alloué à
l'Ukraine soit diminué soit complètement
annuler John Rick vous êtes d'accord
juste dire que
l'industrie d'armement verse énormément
d'argent dans les poches des deux
parties surtout démocrates parce qu'ils
sont en majorité en ce moment et on
verra bien si ma carte s'il devient chez
after majorité s'il tient bon assez
promesses
d'être plus prudent avec l'argent des
des
Américains mais ce que ce qui sera plus
intéressant à mon avis sera
l'investigation qui sera sûrement lancée
par les républicains contre le fils de
bail enterbye et sur ses affaires
personnelles c'est évident que bin le
fils bye
est plutôt corrompu il a fait des choses
que les clientes
permettent normalement
en ce moment
il est très vulnérable à cause son fils
et c'est là où ça va vraiment péter
vraiment
la pauvre femme qui ne peut pas nourrir
ses enfants d'investiguer le fils de
balika
sur la tête franchement et quand on dit
que la démocratie est en péril c'est de
ça qu'on parle Trump qui ment le menteur
en chef depuis deux ans qui dit j'ai
gagné l'élection pourtant il est pas à
la Maison Blanche il est pas dans Air
Force One mais bon j'ai gagné et il a
fait croire à des millions de supporters
les 70 millions qui ont voté pour lui je
note au passage que Biden en a eu 7
millions de plus mais bon et ces gens
maintenant il a il a attaqué la
véritable fondation de la démocratie en
faisant douter
l'intégrité des élections à tous ces
supporters ce n'est pas juste farfelu
c'est dangereux c'est dangereux mais
c'est pas le sujet
aux élections présidentielles on est au
mitterme il y a du temps qui s'est passé
on parle de l'Ukraine on parle de
l'argent qui est dépensé par le moi qui
suis en 2020 c'est bien vous êtes en
tout cas les démocrates pardon les
républicains risquent voudraient un
certain nombre impit Biden ou pas
oui ou non on peut pas faire de
généralités si vous voulez qu'on ait
effectivement des raisonnements très
simpliste binaires alors vous m'avez pas
vous mettez pas monsieur de Harper vous
invitez pas bon ami je sais pas parce
qu'elle est très sur Trump c'est très
c'est l'obsession
qui ont déjà été fait ça devant même pas
qui parlait démocrates non mais parler
le président qui a eu le plus de de
procédures d'un pitchment non non mais
comme vous parlez de passer moi aussi je
vais parler du passé faisant les comptes
faisant les bilans vous disent que les
gens ont dit que les démocrates ont fait
de motif parce que vous avez fait parce
que nous disons qu'on pourrait dire que
le chômage est au plus bas depuis 50 ans
je compte il devrait y avoir des
procédures en tout cas si les
républicains l'emportent en tout cas
Donald Trump je sais que vous voulez pas
qu'on mais malheureusement parler il
était là pendant toute cette campagne on
l'a vu on avait même l'impression qu'il
y avait une sorte de de bagarre entre
Trump d'un côté et qui soutenait ses
dauphins et puis Biden de l'autre avec
Obama bien sûr pour pour l'aider et
Donald Trump était tellement présent que
dans l'Ohio a daton il y a 3 jours et
bien il a dit quelque chose
il n'y a qu'un seul choix pour mettre
fin à cette folie si vous soutenez le
déclin la chute de l'Amérique vous devez
absolument voter pour les fous
démocrates de la gauche radicale lave
crazy people
et si vous voulez arrêter la destruction
de notre pays et sauver le rêve
américain alors mardi vous devez voter
républicain pour engendrer la vague
rouge géante que nous attendons tous
il a dit qu'il allait faire une grande
annonce le 15 novembre à Marc à la Gaule
donc si c'est il est présent là Vanessa
oui
il faut pas être naïf on sait très bien
qu'elle ait la technique de
communication de Trump il essaie de tout
le temps être d'occuper le territoire et
alors les démocrates et les journalistes
effectivement s'engouffent dans la
brèche parce que c'est parce que c'est
un bon client et effectivement dire que
le 15 novembre juste avant l'éditeur
mais va se passer quelque chose ça c'est
que c'est un film d'Hollywood c'est à
dire que bon ça tout en attente en
haleine les journalistes ne parlent que
ça les démons vous n'y croyez pas qu'il
pourrait se présenter en 2024 j'ai pas
la réponse je ne suis pas son attaché de
presse John Loïc MacArthur votre
réaction il va se prendre sa revanche
Donald Trump
bah oui il a déjà pris sa revanche
représenter de l'avoir trail de l'avoir
trahi et non non je suis pas certain
parce que ça dépend des résultats demain
mais je veux dire quelque chose
d'optimiste parce que bien sûr je
déteste trempe c'est l'horreur mais mais
finalement il est en train il est en
train de de diviser le parti de déchirer
le parti républicain il a traité son
candidat le candidat qu'il a qu'il a pu
dans l'oreille JD 20 dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure il a traité de [__]
c'est incroyable ce qui vient dire alors
le démocrate le démocrate tien
maintenant il se moque ces derniers
jours de cette
idiotie c'était insulte c'était injure
qu'il a lancé contre son candidat en
même temps il a insulté en de santé le
gouvernement de la Floride très
populaire et un rival potentiel
dans deux ans en 20 000 20 24 contre
Trump alors il y a une dispute interne
au parti républicains qui pourraient
finalement sauver le pays je sais pas si
mais ce qui va se présenter à votre avis
vraiment se passer comme ça
je suis pas certain ça dépend de son de
son état juridique et parce qu'il a très
peur de perdre il a très très peur de
perdre et si les battu de nouveau
peut-être dans les primaires
républicains peut-être l'élection
générale il sera humilié humilié et ce
type a vraiment peur d'être humilié
vous pensez vous qui va prendre il va
estomper d'aller jusqu'au bout et
prendre sa revanche tant que ça depuis
deux ans évidemment qui va se
représenter c'est un secret de
polichinelle de nombreux commentateurs
politiques aux États-Unis ont d'ailleurs
on offre écouter des conversations de
conseiller d'autres Trump qui lui aurait
conseillé d'arrêter de faire la
promotion de sa propre campagne au lieu
de promouvoir les candidats républicains
puisqu'il a tendance quand même à
beaucoup ramener la couverture
médiatique vers lui pour la simple et
bonne raison qu'il est en campagne
évidemment qu'il est en campagne pour
lui-même et pas pour le parti
républicain puisque comme vous l'avez
rappelé comme on l'a vu dans le sujet il
insulte de nombreux candidats
républicains qui se met à dos et
pour ceux qui ne se rallient pas à sa
cause sont écartées du parti républicain
comme liste Chinese dans le Wyoming par
exemple et porter de Biden alors lui
aussi 2024
on refait le mot refrain le match en
2024 Biden 3 oui
je n'ai pas amené ma boule de cristal
Biden c'est déjà prononcé dessus il a
dit qu'il allait se représenter
évidemment il est obligé de dire ça
parce que s'il dit le contraire il est
tout de suite hors-jeu pour les deux ans
qui viennent bon ça c'est de la
politique alors après dans deux ans
est-ce que sa femme va pas lui dire
allez Joe il est temps de prendre ta
retraite je ne sais pas
on va voir en tout cas s'il y avait un
rematch Biden Trump je vous rappelle
qu'il y a personne qui mobilise les
démocrates comme Donald Trump donc Biden
le remportera à nouveau c'est ce que
vous pensez Vanessa moi je pense qu'on
prépare la raison pour la parce que je
me suis toujours été étonnée mais
peut-être que Amy ou monsieur peut me
donner la réponse pourquoi on a mis un
octogénaire
à ce poste qui est quand même
physiquement
je me suis déjà prononcé sur le fait que
j'ai trouvé que les leaders étaient âgés
quel que soit le camp donc ça c'est mon
opinion comme on dit personnel donc
place aux jeunes vous ah oui
les 70 80 alors laissez-moi laissez moi
finir je pense que une des raisons c'est
aussi une préparation d'une candidature
qui de temps en temps ressort de Michel
Obama vous comprenez que si on a mis non
mais si on avait mis quelqu'un qui
faisait d'autres qui étaient susceptible
de faire deux mandats c'est difficile
après deux mandats de revenir le temps
qui passe c'est quand même assez
important et je ne suis encore une fois
je me prends là je me prononce pas pour
les au nom des républicains en opinion
mon analyse je pense que il tient il
chauffe la place si vous voulez garde la
place pour d'autres candidats ou alors
c'est que vraiment cette génération ne
veut pas laisser la main et qu'il faut
qu'elle meure pour que de nouveaux
leaders plus jeunes pour une nouvelle
génération vous vous pensez aussi ah ben
moi je suis pas contre et c'est vrai
qu'il y a énormément de candidats à côté
démocrate qui sont prêts qui attendent
qui n'attendent que ça se bouscule au
portillon merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous Juliette merci beaucoup
Vanessa Bircher
merci John Rick MacArthur vous étiez
avec nous au moment duplex de New York
merci aussi à nous envoyer spéciaux
Julie d'une gelove qui était avec nous
en Géorgie et puis Loïc piala qui était
avec nous en Arizona que vous pourrez
suivre ce soir parce qu'il y avait bien
sûr on va suivre en direct ces élections
américaines ça sera toute la nuit sur
France 24 restez avec nous